armin laschet und markus söder haben so
einiges gemeinsam sie führen große
parteien haben ambitionen auf die
kanzlerkandidatur
und sie haben ein problem masken
geschäfte man kann fast von einem
wettstreit bei der kandidaten sprechen
in beiden parteien brechen die fälle auf
und eigentlich ist es mehr ein problem
für markus söder die affäre in seiner
partei die auch ein längeres
verfallsdatum hat die eine größere
geschichte hat die die frage
grundsätzlich aufwirft wie weit ist
dieser amigo partei csu noch immer
dieselbe das macht es ihm weit
problematischer wenn er verliert ein
stück weit den nimbus des saubermannes
des starken mannes der aufräumt mit dem
csu bundestagsabgeordneten georg nüßlein
beginnt ende februar die masken affäre
nüßlein war gesundheitsexperte der union
und bestens vernetzt jetzt ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft wegen bestechlichkeit
nüßlein weist die vorwürfe zurück
laut der ermittler soll der deal so
gelaufen sein
zu beginn der korona pandemie haben ist
ein masken an die gesundheitsministerien
im bund und in bayern vermittelt ein
millionengeschäft nüßlein soll 660.000
euro bekommen haben
das geld soll vom masken lieferanten an
eine firma mit sitz auf der karibikinsel
st vincent geflossen sein wo steuern und
finanzkontrolle minimal sind
direktor der firma ist der deutsche
geschäftsmann und lobbyist thomas
limberger der mittlerweile in
untersuchungshaft sitzt und die vorwürfe
ebenfalls bestreitet über ein konto in
liechtenstein soll das geld an nüßlein
in den landkreis günzburg geflossen sein
aus günzburg kommt auch nüßlein
parteifreund alfred sauter haben er hat
als anwalt den liefervertrag für den
masken deal ausgearbeitet der
landtagsabgeordnete ist ein csu
urgestein unter edmund stoiber war er
justizminister horst seehofer
überreichte ihm das bundesverdienstkreuz
der bestechungsvorwurf sei abenteuerlich
und konstruiert sagt sauter die
ermittlungen aber bringen seinen
parteivorsitzenden in bedrängnis
in der krise zu helfen ist gut damit
groß kasse zu machen natürlich nicht
wenn man die summen die da im raum
stehen
alfred sauter soll 1,2 millionen euro
bekommen haben das geld soll den
gleichen weg genommen haben über die
karibik und liechtenstein wieder nach
günzburg
dort ist der empfänger sauters csu
schatzmeister manfred krautkrämer der
betont er sei nur als treuhänder tätig
gewesen
ein teil des geldes ist hier angekommen
bei der bürgerstiftung landkreis
günzburg die soziale projekte fördert
deren vorsitzender war überrascht als
krautkrämer ihn anrief und der stiftung
eine spende von 470.000 euro überwies
krautkrämer hat nicht gesagt woher kommt
und er hat auch gleich gesagt das sind
spender die nicht öffentlich genannt
werden wollen dass das ist moralisch
unsauber
das kann so nicht sein und deshalb
wollen sie das geld nicht haben wir
wollen das geld nicht haben wir wollen
alles aufklären nicht nur so dass csu
muss einiges aufklären sondern auch die
cdu und armin laschet
es geht um seine rolle bei geschäften
mit der modefirma van laak lasche zum
johannes genannt joe ist influenza und
mode blogger und seit jahren mit van
laak im geschäft ende märz gibt jo
seinem vater die handynummer seines
arbeitgebers laschet ruft van laak chef
christian von daniels an das ergebnis 1
45 millionen euro auftrag der
landesregierung für van laak ohne jede
ausschreibung wir waren damals auf der
suche nach seriösen anbietern möglichst
aus deutschland möglichst aus nordrhein
westfalen
wir haben jeden gefragt den wir kennen
wir haben uns die hände wund telefoniert
gefragt gedrängt gebettelt könnt ihr
eure produktion umstellen petra meyer
aus wuppertal ist überrascht über solche
aussagen ihres ministerpräsidenten
sie hatte masken produzieren lassen
wollte schnell helfen sagt sie
doch an ihrem angebot hatte die
landesregierung kein interesse so das
war die erste
an herrn laschet am 31 märz 70 58
ein schriftliches angebot worauf keiner
reagiert hat beziehungsweise ich habe
eine bestätigung des eingangs bekommen
beschreiben es werden formschreiben wir
melden uns sobald keine ahnung pandemie
vorbei ist dann gab es aber den
großauftrag anfahren wie bewerten sie
das ohne ausschreibung für mich sieht es
nach vetternwirtschaft aus petra maria
hat einen anwalt eingeschaltet und
geklagt gegen ein masken geschäft des
landes mit van laak
das führte dazu dass das land in
anbetracht der erfolgsaussichten die wir
natürlich hatten den auftrag mit van
laak freiwillig rückgängig gemacht hat
um sich eben die blamage einer
entscheidung zu ersparen
die landesregierung hat den masken
auftrag jetzt neu ausgeschrieben die
opposition fordert aufklärung landtag
nordrhein westfalen am vergangenen
freitag die spd greift den nicht
anwesenden ministerpräsidenten laschet
wegen der van laak deals an die ganze
vergabepraxis war nicht in ordnung die
ganze sache stinkt zum himmel
vielen herzlichen dank den vorwurf der
vetternwirtschaft hatte laschet von
anfang an empört zurückgewiesen
der vorwurf der spd ist wirklich schäbig
uns haben ärzte angerufen pfleger
angerufen die erzählt haben zum teil
haben wir die masken mehrere tage
getragen weil keine neuen medizinischen
masken verfügbar waren
gleichzeitig war der kampf um die masken
brutal doch beim ersten mega deal mit
verlag ging es gar nicht um masken
sondern um schutzkittel zehn millionen
stück für 45 millionen euro
wie diese bestellliste des
gesundheitsministeriums zeigt einer der
größten schrott aufträge des landes auf
jeden fall der auch sehr teuer gewesen
ist mit fast 45 millionen titel zu
kaufen die kein mensch brauchen kann
denn die kittel von van laak chef
christian von daniels waren fragwürdig
zertifiziert gerieten in die kritik von
lag schutzkittel liegen ungenutzt in nrw
herum klinik sortiert von lars kittel
aus uniklinik bemängelt schutzkittel von
münchen
gladbacher firma und viele andere
schlagzeilen
auch der tüv äußert bedenken in einer
internen mail heißt es
de kittel falsch gekennzeichnet
reißfestigkeit mangelhaft der schutz
scheint nicht gegeben
der kittel auftrag des landes anfang lag
war aber nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen
fest steht in der pandemie verdoppelte
das unternehmen seinen jahresumsatz
armin laschet hat nicht nur persönlich
sondern auch als parteichef mit der
maske affäre zu kämpfen
der cdu-abgeordnete nikolas löbel hat
für die vermittlung von schutzmasken
rund 250.000 euro erhalten
parteichef laschet hatte tagelang die
kameras gemieden versuchte in skandal
kleinzuhalten gehandelt hat ein anderer
fraktionschef ralph brinkhaus ließ alle
abgeordneten eine ehrenerklärung
unterzeichnen
armin laschet hat auch was die
bewältigung der cdu masken affäre
anbelangt eigentlich nie
das führungs format unter beweis
gestellt derjenige der so weit stärker
in aktion trat war der fraktionschef im
rat brinkhaus die führungs autorität die
armin laschet in der korona krise nicht
bewiesen hat wo er im gegenteil durch
eine sehr laxe haltung eher
unsicherheiten geführt hat die wird
unterstrichen durch seine nicht klare
position in der masken affäre
jetzt aber geht es um die machtfrage
armin laschet oder markus söder
wer ist der bessere kanzler kandidat
doch auch der csu chef kämpft in bayern
mit der masken affäre in mindelheim
treffen wir den csu landtagsabgeordneten
franz josef pschierer
der korruptionsverdacht wirke wären
corona wie ein brandbeschleuniger sagt
er
das zeitlich aufeinander treffen
eine krise einer pandemie die ganze
bevölkerung betrifft die unsere
gesellschaftsstrukturen vielleicht
nachhaltig beeinflusst dass an dieser
krise geld verdient wird ist für den
normalen bürger ein vertrauensverlust in
die demokratie und deshalb müssen wir
aufpassen dass hier nicht ein schaden
bleiben vor allem die einzelhändler und
unternehmer in seinem stimmkreis seien
sauer
peter schäfer das seit über vier monaten
in seinem autohaus keine autos mehr
verkaufen nur reparaturen sind erlaubt
schlimm für uns es gibt ja aktuell nicht
mal eine perspektive wo es hingeht und
dann als gipfel des ganzen gibt's
abgeordneten die nichts anderes als
sorge haben dass sie sich
millionenbeträge als provisionen
us-geschäft einstecken
dann stehe ich auch dass solche
politiker dadurch an zustimmung
verlieren und dadurch auch solche
parteien masken affäre und corona
missmanagement die umfragewerte der
union sind im keller
nach ostern wollen sich armin laschet
und markus söder einigen wer
kanzlerkandidat wird
[Musik]